-Hey, Fred! -Hey, Jimmy!
-The show's about to start! You ready?!
-Yeah, let's go! -Let's do this, buddy.
Oh! -Ah!
-W-We're stuck!
-We're stuck in a door frame?
-I can't -- I can't get out.
-Help! We're stuck! -Help! Help!
We're stuck in the door! -Can someone help, please?
-Help! -Please?!
-Help! We're stuck! -Please help.
-Fred -- Fred, are you falling asleep?
Fred, wake up! Wake up! Fred!
-[Groans] Sorry. I think the body heat made me tired.
-I'm getting hungry. -Me too.
I have a granola bar in case
I ever get stuck in a door frame, but I can't reach it.
-Oh, gosh. How are we gonna get out?!
-I think we're gonna have to cut off your arm.
-Why do we have to cut off my arm?
-Because I'm the one with the bone saw.
-Hold on. Your shoulder pads. They're inflatable, right?
-Of course they are.
[ Pop, air hissing ]
[ Both sigh ]
[ Both chuckle ]
-Let's go do the show.
-Oh, wait! I forgot my granola bar.
-Oh, I'll get it.
Aah! Come on! -Come on!